will people who have privately held
loans will they at some point become
eligible for this forgiveness because
they no longer are
those
provide relief as many people as
possible thank you
how you doing people I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it's October 18
2022 we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV if you have not
subscribed yet especially to our Rumble
Channel please go ahead and tap that
button you will be rewarded in ways you
cannot possibly imagine I like that cold
open today it might be worth later you
rewinding and watching it again just
that that cold empty stare of Biden when
the meds wear off at a certain point
during the day you know they can drug
them or whatever they do to him to get
them going maybe they seven cups of
coffee I don't know what they're doing
they can have these brief moments of
sort of semi-coherence then it usually
breaks down with the teleprompter and
then when he's off prompter you know
it's it's sort of mess see and
Meandering and that whole thing that one
was just sort of a staring into the
abyss hello darkness my old friend but
we have a tremendous program for you by
the way thank you for so many people
watching our happy hour last night I
think we're going to try to do uh some
more of those uh it's nice talking to
you good people with a little tequila in
my hand and whatever's in your hand
whatever drink that is you weirdo uh but
uh the show today really is about how
things are flipping in real time uh we
went from basically everything being a
referendum on Republicans to really
everything being a referendum on
Democrats what I mean by that is the
meme for the last couple let's say two
years since Biden has taken over is that
Republicans are mean about January 6th
then Trump and Ultra Maga and they want
to control women with abortions blah
blah blah but now as we enter the
stretch run the two and a half three
weeks right before this midterm election
which is big they always say it's big
it's always the election of a lifetime
but this one is freaking big people it
really is uh the thing has flipped and
it really isn't about those issues
anymore what is it about well it's about
a lot of things that we've been talking
about here it's about the Democrats
radical police policies when it comes to
race when it comes to gender inflation
uh and their General State of tyranny
that they're trying to oppress us all
with uh so that's what we're going to
focus on today with video clips pretty
impressive uh before we get to any of
that let me talk to you guys about
Bonner private wine you know you guys
have heard me talk about the amazing
extreme altitude wines from Bonner wine
the Bonner wine partnership before uh I
just had a bottle of their 9 000 foot
Malbec the other night with a picana a
great cut of meat it's grilling season
and the flavors go great with any meat
you're going to have they're unlike any
wine you've ever tasted Blackberry
leather smoking a little dark cherry
these wines are almost impossible to get
on your own because the producers deep
in the Andes Mountain make a very
limited quantity today I have an amazing
offer that I have never ever had before
if you visit
bonnerprivatewines.com Dave you'll not
only get 50 off your wine plus free
shipping you'll also get a bonus model
of small batch limited production wine
from their exclusive Wine Cellar that's
four bottles for the price of three it's
a deal that's hard to turn down if
you're a wine lover like myself just
visit bonnerprivatewines.com Dave to
claim your bonus bottle and become part
of America's most unique wine club all
right so
as we've watched things flip as we've
watched parents show up to school board
meetings and say hey could you stop
teaching my kids to be racist could you
stop telling my little boy that he's
actually a girl that sort of radical
stuff as we've watched that sort of
bubble into mainstream now what is
happening is those issues are now the
important things on people's mind when
it comes to this election in a couple
weeks on top of say you know the economy
that seems to be flailing and this very
bizarre war with Russia and Ukraine and
a whole bunch of other stuff but the
machine the machine loves people who
obfuscate the truth the machine loves
people who confuse the issues and who
will tell you that all the woke stuff is
good while you inherently know that it's
bad and much more than that so here's
John Oliver he does is this show on HBO
what I don't even know where it is it is
on HBO John Oliver who was you know he
was on The Daily Show with Jon Stewart
years going they've had a very similar
career trajectory which is you guys were
somewhat sane liberals thought of as a
voice of reason say 10 years ago and you
guys are just off the rails bananas
lefties who now want to blame the West
for everything and demonize everybody oh
and chop off children's genitals here's
a little clip from the John Oliver show
that apparently is on HBO it's one of
these things that people nobody ever
talks about it you don't know anyone
I've watched John Oliver last night that
was a good thing but the machine loves
him he gets a lot of money to do a
corporate show where he's really into
having your children's genitals chopped
off and in this segment you'll note he
uh talks about my buddy and many time
Reuben report guest Chris Ruffo so much
of the conversation around anti-trans
laws involves massively overheated
rhetoric that does not match the reality
of kids actual situations and
interestingly a lot of it's been fueled
by some of the same players behind the
critical race Theory Panic who as we
discussed in February we're using it as
a wedge issue to promote school choice
in fact one key architect of the CRT
Panic Christopher Ruffo recently pivoted
to attacking trans rights and he has
openly discussed the strategy behind
doing that what I'm looking at and it's
just kind of an ongoing series I just
started it is to take that same system
of reporting that same style of
reporting as I did with critical race
Theory but now taking a look at gender
ideology what's happening right now is
parents are feeling that they're feeling
though oh this is kind of weird I'm kind
of uncomfortable with this but I'm
scared to speak out and so what we have
to do is we have to give them the kind
of media narrative kind of a a
justification or validation or
substantiation of their concerns to say
hey this is the kind anything they're
teaching in schools and then we have to
give them the language where they can
speak about it with confidence they can
speak about it directly and they could
speak about it with the requisite level
of aggressiveness that it's going to
take to say hey wait a minute we have to
stop this yeah he's basically giving
people a script to repeat very
deliberate in how he tries to influence
public opinion but in the conservative
Playbook that tactic is a really big one
linking discussion of gender identity to
sexual predation and teachers grooming
students
yeah it is kinda because it's true and
there's a lot of evidence of that uh
John Oliver I don't know if you'd know
this but it would be weird let's say if
you sent your kids to public school and
then the teacher let's say your kid was
in second or third grade and then the
teacher was discussing uh gender
identity or sexuality or anything of a
sexual nature with your child privately
and not bringing it to your attention as
if they have ownership over your child
as if they are allowed to call your
child a different name and hide it from
you and you guys know the that this is
all actually happening right this is why
Libs of tick tock keeps getting banned
on Twitter because they just expose the
videos of this you guys know that this
is exactly what the don't say gay bill
here in Florida was all about it had
nothing to do with being gay you again
as I've said 400 bajillion times we
checked uh this has nothing to do with
being gay you would not not want a
straight male teacher talking to a
little second grade girl about gender or
sex or her body or anything like that
this is all just obvious stuff but of
course what John Oliver is doing there
is is just sort of Playbook it's just
classic 101 Democrat operative corporate
media Playbook which is that somehow
Chris Ruffo is a bigot somehow he hates
trans people or anything else as far as
I know Chris doesn't have a problem if
someone as an adult would like to live
however they see fit in the privacy of
their own life right as far as I know
and that's certainly I can say that for
myself without question uh Chris rufo
before I just go into a I'll go into a
little bit more first one of the
interesting things that uh that Oliver
said there was that rufo is using the
trans issue as a wedge issue to promote
school choice
as if that's a bad thing now it is a bad
thing for Democrats and leftists they
hate Choice everyone should be for
school choice and as many Charter
Schools as possible and as many private
schools as possible and say instead of
funding these giant public education
systems that are failing basically
across the board ironically Florida with
no state income tax has pretty solid uh
solid public education but you would
want as much Choice as possible you
would want to fund the students so you
could give the parents say x amount of
dollars I know it's not give because
it's their tax money but okay let's
here's how the game is played unless
we're abolishing taxes altogether you
say to the parents hey here's x amount
of dollars here are the schools that you
can choose from and this one might be
more in line with your thinking this one
might be closer to where you live and
that might be important to you
the all the issues that would be
relevant to that right so you would want
choice but Democrats and leftists they
hate choice right they want everyone to
learn the things that they want them to
learn they want everyone to see the
world as they see it and that is a
problem so rufo uh saw that clip and he
had a great tweet on this he says thank
you John Oliver for highlighting my work
I always publicly announce my plan in
advance so these gotcha segments at the
end are a nice confirmation that it
worked we are winning on critical race
Theory and radical gender Theory and
there's nothing you can do to stop us I
thought that was a perfect response he
continued in the thread the left's most
powerful technique is to shame people
for any behavior that deviates from
their narrative but that's not going to
work anymore call us whatever you want
but there is nothing shameful about
protecting our children from racialist
abuse and sexual manipulation
conservatives must have the confidence
that we are in the right against
racialist abuse against radical gender
surgeries for minors let the pundits and
NPCs non-playable characters like John
Oliver mindlessly defend whatever passes
as Elite wisdom they will be judged
harshly later I mean I really can't say
it any better than that I mean I think
what John Stewart what John Oliver what
Jimmy Kimmel all of these cultural taste
makers who are just repeating what the
machine wants them to repeat I think
they are going to regret it I don't
think John Oliver or Jon Stewart or
Jimmy Kimmel would be thrilled if their
second grade son came home and said he
was a girl and that they would
immediately be like get on those puberty
blockers let's get the surgery of course
not they would most likely unfortunately
uh be oh I don't even want to say
Unfortunately they would most likely be
horrified much like how ibram candy
Ibrahim X candy the the woke King how
when he found out that his son I think
it was his second grade son we covered
this uh came home and thought he was
trans thought he was a little girl or
something his words he said that he and
his wife were horrified which of course
just shows you that intersectionality
and all of this woke stuff is absolutely
crazy so I wanted to start with that
because I think it's just a perfect
illustration of how something really
good is happening
it's not working anymore I don't know
anyone who's talking about John Oliver I
don't know anyone who wants their kids
racialized and and genderized and all of
this nonsense I don't and I think these
are now winning issues and I don't have
you know it's not just it's not just
conservatives it's the ex-libs you guys
get it it's it's the whole crew of sane
people have just had enough about all of
that uh and going from sane people let's
go to completely insane people uh we've
got some videotape here from the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC and there's this I guess she's a
daytime host Nicole Wallace who's become
sort of like a almost like a what's her
name who's the woman that we're always
making fun of here I don't remember her
name anymore these people Joy Anne Reed
Joy Joy Joy Reed she's like oh she's
like a white jewelry read and just like
the crazy department and just listen to
this as they're talking about January
6th oh god I've not heard one utterance
of connecting the dots from Christopher
Wray in the days after the deadliest
attack on the U.S Capitol in our you
know in history
Nicole I think that's right and I think
if you look at the scale in terms of the
threat to democracy I mean 9 11 was a
tragedy we lost thousands of lives in a
horrific way are we still mourn to this
day but when you look at something that
is an attack on Democracy something that
could actually bring about a fundamental
change to American governance as we
understand it 911 is nothing compared to
January 6. and the fact that the FBI and
the rest of the government if they are
not on the same sort of War footing that
we were on in the weeks and months and
years after 9 11 shame on everyone
all right so first off uh Peter strzok
or whatever his name is he basically was
one of the two FBI agents who spent
years trying to take down Trump and
trying to make that trump-russia
connection which of course it turned out
that was there was absolutely no Trump
connection so the fact that they even
put this guy on TV the fact that he's
even willing to show his face tells you
everything you need to know about that
network uh that line about in essence
um you know January 6 being worse for
the country than 9 11 is so is so
profoundly evil and and wrong and and
actually disgusting you guys know I was
in New York for 9 11.
UM
thousands of people died you know what
happened on January 6th a bunch of
people with no weapons went to the seat
of power to have their voices heard
some of them broke some property they
did they had no plans to take over the
government remember somebody had a Lego
set of the capital and people thought
that that meant they were going to take
over the government there were no plans
they didn't kidnap anybody in many cases
the the Capitol Police actually moved
barricades and people walked in they
took selfies in Nancy Pelosi's office
um that is not to diminish you you know
the certain level of uh you can't break
into places if you know you can't break
windows and things of that nature but
it's just completely untrue and also as
you guys know I've only talked about
January 6th year I don't know two three
times maybe because the whole the whole
thing is a farce right this whole
hearing is an absolute farce just like
all the impeachments were a farce and
the Russia stuff was a farce and all of
it was a farce but see if you're
watching those things if you have
friends that are watching those things
they're being brainwashed with that
nonsense someone might have watched that
uh that television program and said Mike
God January 6 was worse than 9 11. about
3 000 people died in 9 11. it was an
attack on our democracy right from a
terrorist organization here we had a
bunch of people with American flags
wandering through the capital oddly they
weren't burning down all of the streets
Across America that might have been an
attack on Democracy but well you know
I'm just some crazed right-wing Maniac
anyway here's a little bit more from
MSNBC we've got Jen sahi a former White
House Press Secretary who was the
biggest paid liar in America for two
years then she resigned to go be a paid
liar for a giant Corporation MSNBC and
here she is with this guy shoddy Hamid
uh and you know they don't like us very
much and and they really wish they could
get rid of us and it's odd that they say
that on television as we look to 2024
because my former boss also talked about
how one Trump term is one thing two
Trump terms is another thing totally
different thing yeah what should we what
lessons should Americans take from what
has happened around the world if there
are extended years of a government in
place who's fighting against democracy
and fighting against fundamental rights
of people what could happen with more
years yeah well so you're right that
it's a universal thing and we can talk
about Europe has its own cases where in
Italy we might have the first far-right
Prime Minister since Mussolini and that
person will have come to power through
elections or the Sweden Democrats a
party with Neo-Nazi Origins so it's not
just America it's happening all over the
place because
um we're not debating economic issues
anymore we're debating cultural issues
identity issues issues around religion
so I think we have to accept that people
who we completely disagree with are
sometimes going to win so there's what
74 million Trump uh supporters voters we
can't just wish them away they're not
going to disappear so then we have to
find a way to live with them even if we
think they're bad people even if we
think they're a threat to everything we
hold dear because what out what's the
other option that's in front of us and
that's a challenge because a lot of
people will say Well they're deplorable
and we can't find a way to live with
them I try not to group people the way
he does and say that whole group of
people is deplorable that whole group of
people is evil so I'll just talk about
that guy directly I mean he's he's a
complete uh authoritarian Maniac what
he's telling you as he's saying we can't
really wish them away we have to have
them in society what he's really saying
is we don't want them in society and
that is what deplorables is all about
and they all just sit there and what
they're showing you and this is why I
always talk about that thin veneer of
progressivism they caught they at the
very top level the very simple thin
veneer if you listen to a progressive it
all sounds good tolerance diversity
inflation reduction act all these things
sound good but then you peel off that
veneer and you realize oh they are
actually the really hysterical
authoritarians those are the people that
seemingly would uh I don't know put
people in camps perhaps those are the
people who would love to get rid of some
of the people in society they're also
accusing Trump of uh I believe saki said
taking away people's fundamental rights
guys did we do any Googling on that on
the Google machine about any of the
fundamental rights that Trump took away
from people did we uh find any we could
not find anything
um he actually was on stage with a
rainbow flag before he was president I
don't even like the rainbow the gays
have destroyed the rainbow but the point
is nobody's rights were taken away so
every single thing that they say is a
lie while they and they accuse you of
all the things that they are but okay
you guys know I don't like focusing just
on the negative let's focus on some of
the positive well uh Governor Ron
DeSantis right down here in Florida he's
in the midst of a campaign re-election
right now and obviously he's gonna crush
this this absolute clown Charlie Chris
who was a Former Republic and now a
Democrat he stands for absolutely
nothing he has no support he's he's just
a vapid awful human he used to also be
he used to be gay it was a big thing
there was a documentary written about it
he was a closeted anti-gay gay
Republican but now that sort of got
whitewashed because when you're a
Democrat you know all your history uh
just disappears anyway that doesn't even
matter really anyway he's just he's just
nothing point is DeSantis who has spent
the last couple weeks down in Southwest
Florida and all over the coast making
sure that power is on the people are
safe that they're getting food that
they're getting supplies I mean he and
his wife have been out there every
single day I'm as you know very proud to
be a Floridian
um here he is talking about how the
machine operates and that it's not just
coming after him it's coming after
everybody
but uh
so you got to be right on the issues you
got to understand that the stakes are
high you gotta use common sense you
gotta have a good vision and stand for
the right things but in this day and age
there is no substitute for courage you
have to be willing to go out there
knowing that they are going to come
after you and it's not just people like
me who's Governor if a parent speaks out
at a school board meeting you know they
were going to mobilize the FBI to go
after the parents uh going to school
board meetings if you have other folks
involved and get out to vote all this
stuff you could absolutely be targeted
you could be smeared by the media you
could be smeared by the left but these
are sacrifices we just have to make
because it's too important not to
isn't that good isn't that good like he
didn't say hey we gotta figure out what
we can do with these people he said we
have to have courage to confront them
how about that that's pretty good
stand up for yourself stand up straight
with your shoulders back say what you
believe fight earnestly and honestly for
a better country a country that we've
unfortunately let's slip away but I
think we can we're at the precipice of
grabbing back I think that would be
pretty good and when you do that when
you show courage and you show the
machine that you're not going to just
endlessly take it but you're actually
going to fight back you know what
happens people start following you and
that's exactly what's happening right
here in Florida
well here's what's happened when I got
elected governor in November of 2018
there were close to 300 000 more
registered Democrats in the State of
Florida than Republicans and prior to me
becoming Governor we had never in
Florida history had more registered
Republicans than registered Democrats
well the the books are closed for
November's election so the registration
deadline is passed and I could report
that we now have over 300
000 more registered Republicans than
Democrats
pretty sweet man and I am very proud to
say I just had to double confirm it
while we were showing you that clip that
there are four in this room alone there
are four newly registered uh Republicans
not only new Floridians who pay taxes
and are good members of the community
and you guys are out there partying
eating dinners all the time putting
money back into the economy buying stuff
you got a beanie the other day didn't
you you're the only guy in Florida
wearing a beanie oh that's an old Beanie
anyway uh yes there is something
happening by by DeSantis doing the right
thing not locking down not closing the
schools not destroying the economy and
destroying the lives of Untold amount of
people you know what happened now the
proof is in the pudding the numbers are
really looking good and and he's going
to crush this guy here's a tweet from my
buddy Brendan Leslie who works for
Florida's voice which is a online paper
mostly Southwest Florida they just
compared what's going on at these
rallies so they're on the left obviously
is the Ron DeSantis rally you know I
don't know that's got to be 100 if not
thousands of people and then several old
people uh at a Charlie Crist rally and
I'm told that he was asking them how
many of them were going to vote for Ron
DeSantis and they all raised their hands
so there you go but let's continue
because I don't want to make this just
about Florida there are good things
happening all over the country one place
where there's a couple good things
happening is in Arizona where there are
two races so there's the senate race and
Blake Masters uh is starting I think to
really pick up some momentum I think the
debate went really well for Blake
Blake's been on the show a couple times
uh so that's looking pretty good and
then there's the gubernatorial debate
and Carrie Lake who I've also had on the
show we've tried to get Katie Hobbs on
the show she hasn't responded Katie
Hobbs also refuses she's a Democrat
running for governor obviously she also
refuses to debate Carrie Lake she said
well we only got 30 days left and we're
just so busy and it's like what could
you be busy with that you can't debate
your opponent I mean it's it's actually
it's actually embarrassing almost
disqualifying I would say anyway the
mainstream media is finally realizing
they can't hide from Carrie so they put
her on CNN on Dana bash's show and just
watch how they treat her and watch how
effective she is in her response you
called the 2020 election corrupt Stolen
Rotten and rigged and there was no
evidence of any of that presented in a
court of law or anywhere else
that any of those things are true so why
do you keep saying that
well there's plenty of evidence we had
740 000 ballots with no chain of custody
those ballots shouldn't have been
counted the people don't trust our
elections they haven't since 2000 I'm a
reporter I've been sitting on your side
of the desk for a long time and since
2000 we have Americans who don't trust
our elections in 2000 in 2004 they
didn't trust the elections in 2016
Kamala Harris Amy Klobuchar and Hillary
Clinton everybody on the Democrat side
said the election had problems Miss Lake
there definitely has been some of that
but I want to say in 2000 Al Gore
conceded in 2004 John Kerry receded and
conceded in 2016 Hillary Clinton
conceded and we didn't see that in 2020
Stacy Abrams never conceded she still
hasn't I don't hear CNN calling her an
election denier we have the right it's
protected with our first amendment to
question our government and to question
elections no questions we still have the
First Amendment yeah we still have the
First Amendment and when you start
seeing the media cancel people for
questioning their government then there
that's when we have a problem I I
totally agree about the First Amendment
you and I are uh benefiting from the
First Amendment as we speak so
you know the best part of that right at
the end of that clip there where she
says you know we have the First
Amendment and Dana Bash goes yep
yep did you see that she goes yep we
have the First Amendment yes we do
um look without rehashing all of the
election stuff the the simple fact is
that what Carrie Lake said there was
true there is it's on video we've shown
it there are the tweets Hillary Clinton
calling Donald Trump an illegitimate
president for four years the entire
machine telling you he was a Russian
plant or a Russian operative Dana Bash
knows that that's all true she knows
it's all true so Carrie is right we are
allowed to question things I don't know
I'll probably be kicked off YouTube for
saying that you're allowed to question
things but you are allowed to question
things and it's not even it's not really
about are you allowed to question things
or not it's like how about both sides
just get equal treatment so if the
Democrats want to do this if the
Democrats for four years when Donald
Trump is President want to say he's an
illegitimate president want to bring up
impeachment want to make up Russia
collusion and all of those things well
then the Republicans should just have
equal opportunity to do such things that
would be a sort of fair even playing
field but that's obviously not what we
have which is why we have a corporate
press that behaves the way they do and a
big Tech machine that sensors as it
wishes let's continue though because
there are some other good things
happening in other states let's go over
to Georgia which is right north of us
here in Florida I don't know what accent
that was that I'm using but does that
sound like a Georgian accent no I don't
know uh
you all shook your head at the same time
uh here is Stacy Abrams and Stacy Abrams
who of course has no resume this is a
woman who the only thing she is known
for besides for setting a record at the
Golden Corral buffet is uh is that she
ran for governor last time and then when
she lost she said that it was an
illegitimate election anyway she's
running again uh and here she is and she
seems to be a little confused about
who's screwing up everything related to
the economy and I want to point out that
Brian Kemp did make promises he promised
to keep us safe but crime has gone up he
promised to protect us and yet he's
attacked our freedoms he has promised to
take care of our families and yet the
rising prices in Georgia are rising
because he refuses to expand Medicaid
because he refuses to tackle the
affordable housing crisis that we have
and he's sitting on 400 million dollars
of our money that he will not spend to
keep us under roofs and in our homes
the rising prices are related to the
fact that he won't expand Medicaid
that's a new one for me I thought that
the rising prices are actually happening
all over the country they're happening a
little bit less in Republican states
because for example right here in
Florida I can bring it oh back to
Florida almost every day we have these
tax breaks that Governor DeSantis has
brought in and that we have these
weekends where they won't charge you for
certain things related to House repair
or other things of that nature but I've
never heard anything about how somehow
because of not funding Medicare properly
the state of Georgia that that's why
prices are rising I mean prices are
rising everywhere because they're
deflating the value of the dollar the
dollar is worth less the markets are
crashing right now everything is
depressed so she just sort of made that
up uh here's the the Governor Brian Kemp
who she's going against and uh he's he's
not having it with her nonsense when I
ran for governor in 2018 I promise to
put hard work in Georgians first ahead
of the status quo and the politically
correct I said shortly after being sworn
in I would work hard as your Governor
every single day for all Georgians
whether you voted for me or not I'm so
optimistic about the future of our state
the lowest unemployment rate in the
history of the state the most people
working in Economic Opportunity in all
parts of our state no matter your ZIP
code or neighborhood Stacy Abrams said
George is the worst state in the country
to live well Marty the girls and I
disagree we think Georgia is the
greatest state in the country to live
work and raise our children and that's
why I'm asking for your vote and support
to keep it that way
look I'm not going to sit here and
pretend that I have every like knowledge
of every in and out and the minutia of
everything that's going on in Georgia
specifically but it's like pretty
obvious which way if you're watching
this whether you're in Atlanta or the
suburbs or wherever you might be it's
pretty obvious which way you have to
vote it's like Stacey Abrams stands for
nothing other than the machine other
than more big government other than
wokeness other than keeping kids in
masks while she would go to these
schools not in a mask and she's
obviously quite overweight and it's like
that's one of the things that we were
told was a comorbidity related to covid
but she could not be in a mask while she
kept kids in Mass these are just not
good people so Brian Kemp is saying hey
she doesn't seem to like Georgia very
much I like Georgia I'm the governor uh
we're doing okay and we're going to keep
trying to do okay so I think that's
pretty much where you're at Georgia but
let's move on to another state there is
Ohio and as you guys know JD Vance who's
been on the show Republican is running
against Tim Ryan Democrat and the debate
which was last week was it was I think a
real knockout for JD over Tim Ryan he
just really went at him we're seeing
Republicans who are finally just not
accepting the endless oh the narrative
is that we are just all racist bigots uh
we're actually going to fight back we're
not just going to take it anymore
we have a hold on JD stop this is this
is disgusting I'd like to get here's
exactly what happens when the media and
people like Tim Ryan accuse me of
engaging the grace great replacement
Theory I'll tell you exactly what
happens Tim what happens is that my own
children my biracial children get
attacked by scumbags online and in
person because you are so desperate for
political power that you'll accuse me
the father of three beautiful biracial
babies of engaging in racism we are sick
of it you can believe in a border
without being a racist you can believe
in the the country without being a
racist and this just shows how desperate
this guy is for political power I know
you've been in office for 20 years Tim
and I know it's a sweet gig but you're
so desperate not to have a real job that
you'll slander me and slander my family
it's disgraceful
right and back right like saying the
truth uh JD happens to be married to an
Indian woman so she is let's say of
brown skin now Tim uh Tim Ryan obviously
doesn't care about that and and that's
the point these these attacks these oh
you are just a racist because you're a
republican you are just a bigot because
you want a border it ain't working
anymore and that's why they're getting
more hysterical that's why they're
always moving to this now democracies
under threat because the cries of racism
really did fall flat and what they've
also done is they've done the boy who
cries wolf now when the real racists are
here when the real bigots get out there
and say and say awful things a lot of
people won't care you know over the last
couple days Kanye West has said some
absolutely bananas racist stuff about
Jews and a lot of people were quiet
about it I was kind of waiting because I
wanted to see how a little more of it
would hash out and I'll con I will
obviously continue to talk about I'm
talking about it right now but he said
without question like the worst sort of
collectivist stuff about Jews but a
certain amount of people are just like
ah we're just tired because they call
everybody a racist so sometimes we're
just going to sit one out that's just
part of how humans are we all have a
certain tolerance uh for nonsense uh
let's continue in Georgia we'll jump
back to Georgia uh here is Marjorie
Taylor green she's an interesting
character uh who can be a little over
the top at times but uh there's some
clarity coming out of this debate with
Marcus flowers the Democrat Party is the
party of child abuse it's the party that
represents grooming children and
sexualizing them in school teaching
anti-white racism in the terms of CRT
education and genital mutilation of kids
kids that can't even get a driver's
license can't get a tattoo and cannot
vote how do you stand there and
represent the Democrat Party as a father
and do you believe in genital mutilation
of children under the age of 18 and and
these puberty blockers that have severe
Health consequence
yeah she's kind of right she's kind of
right like which party is pushing all
the racist stuff in schools right the
neo-racism of equity which party is
pushing all of the gender stuff right we
started at the top of the show with that
with uh with Chris Ruffo so it's like
yeah that to me strikes as a winning
message and we by the way we know it's a
winning message in places that it
wouldn't traditionally be winning
because we know about the Virginia
gubernatorial race right it was not
supposed to go the way that it did but
it did because parents were just like
you know what enough of this woke
nonsense so let's get this to the uh to
the federal level uh let's talk about
Joe Biden because what does Old Joe have
well he doesn't seem to have the economy
he doesn't seem to have a win on the
cultural stuff now that that's turning
so what does he have well he's got fear
here's a tweet
if the republicans in Congress get their
way prices will go up and inflation will
get worse it's that simple now okay look
this is just it's just meaningless
nothing from him right he obviously
didn't write that tweet there is zero
chance in high hell that they allow that
man to hold a telephone you know you
could say all the things you want about
Trump but Trump was tweeting for himself
like there is zero chance that they let
not only let him hold a phone but would
let him have access to Twitter or
anything else right and could you put it
up one more time it's just it's just
again it's just this meaningless fear
thing if republicans in Congress get
their way prices will go up and
inflation will get worse it's that
simple no it's not that simple what do
you mean it's your party that is into
endless Reckless spending and yes a lot
of Republicans sign on to it but I am
fairly certain I am fairly certain that
if Republicans take the house and the
Senate and act as a bulwark to whatever
remaining stuff you or whoever Obama
whoever's in charge you want to get done
uh then we will have less of The
Reckless spending so the the idea that
somehow it's Republicans Republicans who
generally are for lower taxes right red
States several red states have no state
income tax they want budgets they talk
about balanced budgets what do Democrats
talk about now they talk about unlimited
spending that you can just keep spending
and you can just keep printing more
money and then by golly the value of the
dollar goes down and the stock market
starts crashing and we get into a
recession and then what do they do right
in front of our eyes just like an
incredible magic trick they change the
definition of recession right in front
of our eyes it's just bananas but they
can get away with it and do you know why
ladies and gentlemen because of democrat
privilege the only privilege that exists
in the United States if you are a
Democrat you can get everything wrong
you can ruin people's lives you can
steal their money you can lock them in
their house you can ruin their 401ks and
you still remain in power and often get
a job promotion for it and how does that
happen well it might have a little
something to do with the way the leftist
mainstream media the corporate press
covers for you you know it's a competing
narrative Republicans want to talk about
gas prices and the economy and man the
numbers you guys just uh talked about
came out this morning on the inflation
they are going to talk about this number
and they're going to say everything else
that you're hearing from the Democrats
is meaningless because you can't afford
to pay your rent people may feel like
I'm not sure that I can afford to care
about democracy right this is not a U.S
problem let's be clear we have a global
inflation problem there is however
another silver lighting a silver lining
the annual inflation rate has gone down
it's not as bad as it was earlier this
summer 40 believe the economic
conditions will improve and be good in
one year the dollar is surging
employment is very high medicare
premiums are going down the core economy
remains quite strong the job market is
still strong the jobs Market which
remains very strong unemployment sitting
at a more than 50-year low of three and
a half percent on paper a lot of things
look pretty decent there's also news
about social security the Social
Security Administration says benefits
Will Rise by 8.7 percent this is 70
million people they're getting an 8.7
percent increase the largest increase
since 1981. it is the largest in more
than 40 years that's going to help them
fight inflation for next year inflation
is in some ways good news for Social
Security recipients
[Laughter]
inflation is good news for Social
Security recipients it's all such
nonsense you know it's all Republicans
pounce on the economy you see what the
Republicans did they're forcing everyone
to look at the economy that we screwed
up so it's their fault because they're
making us look at it uh it's a worldwide
problem yes the economy is worldwide
because of giant globalization and and
centralization of these big leftist
governments uh yes a lot of Western
nations are having problems but we have
a particular brand of it here but that
guy the guy on I think that was CNN the
dollar is surging what what planet is he
on and also 3.5 percent unemployment I'd
have to check that number actually but
also the the number doesn't fully uh
sort of compare with reality properly
because a huge amount of people have
just selected out of the workforce so
they don't get put on those rolls that's
how it works so 3.5 percent you can go
to almost any store
wherever you are there is a now hiring
sign it's because they cannot even get
people to work despite the fact that
places that years ago were maybe paying
10 bucks an hour for you know sort of an
entry-level job at Target are now paying
15 but people just don't seem to want to
work that that's connected to a whole
series of other issues related to
personal responsibility and a whole
bunch more uh but a lot of this
obviously is connected to the elderly
man pretending to be president and many
Democrats who were running for office
right now are going oh man the ship is
sinking the guy's head ain't right and
we got to distance ourselves from them
uh here is black lesbian press secretary
Karin Jean-Pierre and she's having
trouble running cover for him when asked
uh who's gonna you know invite Biden to
come campaign with him in the last month
having a speech tomorrow in DC he's
given fundraisers in New Jersey New York
he campaigned with Democratic governor
candidates in Massachusetts in Maryland
and he was in California Oregon and
Colorado next week yes he has plans to
be in Pennsylvania and Florida but
behind and close doors with two of the
democratic Kennedy there's a White House
Office of political affairs have they
been getting phone calls from candidates
in some of those other states Arizona
Nevada Georgia Wisconsin Michigan to say
we'd love to have the president come
look I don't have any calls to read out
we don't have any calls or personal
conversations to read out
how the hell would she have call records
what is she the press secretary or
something she doesn't know who's calling
the president and asking them to
campaign for him of course that's
complete nonsense if they wanted Biden
there she would be telling people buy it
in schedule by the way Biden's going to
Arizona tomorrow to campaign with Katie
Hobbs by the way Biden's going over to
Ohio to campaign with Tim Ryan Biden's
going to swing by Georgia and campaign
with uh with Stacey Abrams by the way I
thought my George accent was pretty good
I really thought it was we're in Georgia
now
I'm basically doing some version of big
daddy blanche's father in The Golden
Girls
um
but yes they don't want Biden because
they know what's about to happen
although as I always say give the devil
is due like anything can happen over
these next two weeks nuclear war coveted
six you never know
um but it's not looking good and people
don't want to be attached to Biden how
how much do people not want to be
attached to Biden well here is a video
from Fox Business on how bad it actually
is getting for the elderly man
pretending to be president
more bad news for President Biden this
morning a new Fox News poll shows that
if the election were to happen today
only 33 percent of Voters would vote for
President Biden while a 54 percent say
that they would vote for someone else
okay so I always tell you guys I I try
not to get too caught up in polls
because it depends on the sample size
you know it depends who's picking up the
phone generally the people that are
being pulled they skew a little bit
older in age that being said older
people tend to vote it's a little screwy
but if if they're roughly right on that
that 33 percent of people who voted
provided would vote for him again I mean
we're told the guy got 81 million votes
I can do some basic math in my head
where I think we're at about 27 million
people would vote for him this time that
is not good if you're a Democrat like
that ain't good at all and you know it
ain't good because now MSNBC is even
covering the reality of the situation at
the moment take a look at the latest New
York Times Siena poll Republicans
opening up a 10-point lead among
attendance after being essentially tied
just a month ago Democrats 13-point
Advantage among women in September
that's gone and among female
Independents the biggest swing of all
Democrats leading among that group by 14
points in September now down by 18. as
we said a 32-point swing in just four
weeks so it's very bizarre because we're
if we're watching mainstream media we're
being told that the Republicans are
coming for democracy and that they're
fascists and bigots and all those things
and yet it does seem that the average
American is like yeah I'm kind of into
that so how are you going to explain
that MSNBC how are you going to explain
that CNN
etc
etc you're gonna have a real trouble
explaining that and it's once again why
I have said for years once you call your
political opponents bigots and racists
it's not what you do to them it's what
you do to yourself because you've
painted yourself into a corner and then
you might realize one day that they are
not bigots and racists or that they turn
out to do some good stuff but it's a
little hard to be like ah you know
Hitler ain't that bad that Hitler guy
that I've been screaming about he's
pretty pretty good
so this is the problem that the media
finds itself in this is the problem that
the Democrats are in and much more so
what do we have to do I thought this was
a great way to to finish the show we'll
get to a cold close in just a moment uh
we found this video of Milton Friedman
Milton Friedman who of course is the
famed libertarian Economist uh who once
by the way was on the front page of the
New York Times with me picture of him he
has already passed away it was a picture
of him me Jordan Peterson Ben Shapiro I
think Stephen Crowder was on there a
couple other people as the leaders of
the alt-right that was the front page of
New York Times anyway he was just an
economist a Libertarian Economist he
liked small government he liked low
taxes he didn't like government
interference in people's relationships
with each other and all those things
well he went on Phil Donahue's show this
has got to be early 80s and basically
laid out a beautiful case for for
exactly what we should be fighting for
right now freedom and for democracy and
our ability to exchange goods and ideas
with other people without government
interference it's just so beautiful just
take a look when you when you see the
greed and the concentration of Power
with it aren't you ever did you ever
have a moment of doubt about capitalism
and whether greed's a good idea to run
on well first of all tell me is there
some Society you know that doesn't run
on Greed you think Russia doesn't run on
Greed you think China doesn't run on
great what is greed
of course none of us are greedy it's
only the other fellow who's creating
this the world runs
on individuals pursuing their separate
interests the great achievements
of civilization have not come from
government bureaus
Einstein didn't construct his theory
under order from a from a bureaucrat
Henry Ford didn't revolutionize the
automobile industry that way but it
seems to reward not virtue as much as
ability to manipulate the system and
what does reward virtue you think the a
communist commissary words virtue
you think a Hitler rewards virtue you
think excuse me if you'll pardon me do
you think American president's reward
virtue
do they choose their appointees on the
basis of the virtue of the people
appointed or on the basis of their
political clout
is it really true that political
self-interest is no better somehow than
economic self-helders
you know I think you're taking a lot of
things for granted just tell me where in
the world you find these angels
who are going to organize Society for us
well I don't even trust you to do that
isn't that beautiful and I happen to I
liked Phil Donahue my mom used to always
watch Donahue when I was at school I'd
come home and I think Donahue was on at
four o'clock I would watch Donahue with
my mom he was he was a perfectly fine
host but it's nice when you see someone
sort of put in their place and Milton
Friedman again all he was was basically
a Libertarian Economist who liked free
markets and governments out of the way
um but this reflexive argument of
somehow capitalism and our ability to be
free and make decisions for ourselves
he's so deeply connected to Greed I
believe there was a Gordon gecko guy who
once said that greed is good that we
should all go out there and do what is
best for ourselves and if you do that
within the idea that when you do what's
best for you you start doing what's best
for your family and your community you
don't destroy everything around you are
there going to be bad actors within that
are there going to be genuinely greedy
people who will act unethically and all
those things yes but if you think that
just giving the government the power to
tell you what to do is somehow going to
be better than you doing it for yourself
well then I think you should probably
watch a little more Milton Friedman or
read a book by another alt-right Maniac
Thomas soul that might be good too a
couple comments from the locals
community and then we'll get to the cold
clothes free that's a good handle says
parents are the first line of defense
for their children teachers unions
government entities and anyone pushing
CRT or gender affirming programs should
be canceled immediately I mean look this
is I would say a legitimate reason to
cancel somebody and I can also tell you
that as a father of two young kids like
I will not allow people to abuse my
children obviously whether it is
mentally physically or otherwise and
we're already you know we're very early
on on talking about schooling and all
sorts of stuff like that but like
I'm just simply not going to have it I'm
not going to have it whether that means
we're going to homeschool or pod school
or school choice as I said Florida
happens to have some excellent Public
Schools the district we're in is quite
good so we'll see and also we don't have
thanks to the don't say gay scary bill
by Rhonda said this we have you know
solid schools here that they're not
going to infect these kids with this
nonsense but yeah that's the ultimate
challenge of a parent like you you bring
a child into the world that child is
perfect and you hopefully can teach that
kid some some good ideas along the way
and you can hopefully model something
that they can follow after I'm going to
do that to the best of my ability as a
human being and as a father but then if
you just hand them off and you just hope
that the state and these bureaucrats and
these middle management nobodies and
state you know authorized teachers are
going to teach them the right ideas you
better think about it again maybe that's
how it was 30 years ago and it might
have been right I came from public
education I got a good education
Elementary School junior high school
high school there used to be good public
education there there's not that much of
it anymore and although the progressive
sphere at school choice is a pretty
great thing Kathy says if I had kids and
I was in a blue State I'd move now yeah
you know it's interesting that you
brought that up because at the end of my
conversation with Bill Maher when he's
talking about why he's just sort of
entrenched in La he's like well my
friends are here and my house is here
and my show is here blah blah blah and
it's like that that is all true he he
doesn't have kids so it allows you to
have a certain amount of these I don't
want to say luxury beliefs exactly that
doesn't quite quite encapsulate it but
like when you have kids it does change
the equation because then you really
your ideas have to be put to the test
it's one thing to fight the woke because
you don't want kids indoctrinated it's
one that's one thing and then it's
another thing when they're actually
indoctrinating your own children the
level of escalation of how important it
is to move or fight those people
probably ramped up a bit tiger says the
leftists have lost their minds my
husband would say they would have had to
have had a mind first that is the old
chicken and egg question did they lose
their minds or did they never have them
at all we'll debate that and more
throughout the coming weeks as always
guys if you have not subscribed join us
on Rumble rumble.com reubenreport if you
want to play along during the show and
that's where I post pictures of the kids
and some other more personal stuff
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Megan Kelly is up across
platforms right now and we leave you
with the elderly man pretending to be
president when he once ran for president
and then had to step down and disgrace
adios Democratic presidential candidate
Joseph Biden today faces a controversy
that his opponents could use in raising
questions about his character three
weeks ago at a debate at the Iowa State
Fair he used phrases identical to those
delivered by British labor party leader
Neil kinnick Biden seemed to be claiming
kinnick's vision and life as his own why
is it that my wife was sitting out there
in the audience is the first in her
family to ever go to college what is
Dennis the first woman
in her family in a thousand generations
to be able to get the university my
ancestors who worked in the coal mines
in northeast Pennsylvania and will come
up after 12 hours and play football for
four hours those people who could wait
work eight hours underground and then
come up and play football it's because
they didn't have a platform upon which
to stand there was no platform upon
which they could stand the notion that
every thought or notion or idea you'd
have to go back and find and attribute
to someone I think is quite frankly a
ludicrous the problem here is that
Senator Biden told his audience he'd
just been thinking about these things
and he failed to give any credit at all
to his famous British speechwriter you
know I was thinking on the way over here
now that's a little too much because as
you point out what's behind the words
what's there and a lot of people at rap
on Biden has always been if it's just a
surface I should have said to paraphrase
Neil kinnick
it's the only time I didn't and all the
times I've ever used it but CBS News
found a tape of a second instance it
showed up in Iowa site of the first 1988
caucuses then reappeared in the New York
Times with a new charge that Biden had
appropriated a famous litany from the
late Robert Kennedy about what the gross
national product cannot measure cannot
measure the health of our children the
health of our children the quality of
our education the quality of their
education the joy of their play for the
joy of their play Biden gave Kennedy no
credit he is also quoted or paraphrased
John Kennedy Hubert Humphrey and British
labor party leader Neil kinnick all
without credit